Good morning Hank, it’s Tuesday.
Oh look it’s Hank’s book an
Absolutely Remarkable Thing
which he wants you to know is
available at fine book stores everywhere.
Has been since 2018.
Hank, today we’re doing
something called Mindblowers
with Hank and John where we
share with each other the
most mind blowing facts
that we know.
Oh ok.
Ok Hank here’s my first fact.
Pi calculated to the 38th
digit is precise enough to calculate,
assuming that we knew all the
other numbers, the size of the Milky
Way galaxy to within a
few centimeters.
So like we only
need to know pi to the 38th digit,
but we know pi
to the 31 trillionth digit.
That’s not a fact about pi,
it’s a fact about humans.
We’re amazing.
I can’t get enough of us.
I read a few years ago that
there are probably fragments
of dinosaur bone on the moon.
The asteroid that killed the
dinosaurs probably shed debris
as far as Jupiter.
Another great mind blowing
fact is that science communicators
figured out that bananas were
a really good system
for the scale of radiation.
How so?
They have a little bit of
radiation in them, so eating
one banana exposes you
to some radiation so you
want to know how much
radiation you get flying in a
jet airplane to Europe,
you can do it in bananas.
Now I’m going to have google
how many bananas an
airplane flight is to find
out if it was worth
it to come here to visit you.
Here’s a mind blower that
Hank taught me: before the
big bang is an incorrect idea
because in addition to
creating space as we now
understand it, the Big
Bang created time as
we currently understand it.
To me, the mindblowing fact
is that you can look up into
the sky with a telescope
and see the Big Bang.
This is a great one, Henry
Reich told me this.
If the
universe was infinitely big
and infinitely old, the night
sky would be white.
Why?
Because there would be
light from all of the stars in
every direction, there
would be no space not
taken up by stars because
the universe is infinitely big
and infinitely old.
[Mindblown]
Ok Hank, here’s one
that gets me.
For 99.99%
of human history you
could only hear music if you
were within earshot of
someone who was making it.
And the idea of an album
of recorded music is
younger than Dr. Pepper.
We do not know why
there is matter.
What?
And we do not know, like
in two different ways:
1.)
we don’t know why there
wasn’t an equal amount
of antimatter and matter
created and so everything
annihilated itself.
Like the big
bang should have been like, even Steven.
It big bangs and
then it big smoops.
Well then, space and time
continue to bang, but matter does not.
According to our
understanding of the universe,
a universe without matter
is just as likely if not more
likely than a universe with matter.
And then separately
from that, we don’t know why
matter exists at all.
So we don’t really
know why I’m here.
Oh, definitely not.
Like on way more levels than just those two.
Right like we don’t know
why I’m here, in the sense
that we don’t know why the
atoms that are inside of me exist.
Yeah.
It would be interesting to
look at what makes a fact mind blowing.
I think it’s when it makes me
feel either big or small.
When it recontextualizes my
understanding of myself and my
place in the universe.
Yeah, like I
want to understand my own
emotions because ultimately
I am the most interesting part of the universe.
I would argue that I am.
It’s weird, do you not wake
up in the morning and your
first thought is of me
and my needs?
Some days when it’s a really
bad day, I do think, well we are
on an infinitely tiny speck.
Yeah.
On the one hand, it’s that feeling of
wonderful smallness.
Which you
would think would be sad, but isn’t.
But on the other hand, there’s the
feeling of like, well there might
not have been matter.
So in that
sense I am quite something.
This whole thing is weird.
Thank you for coming to my TED talk.
Hank I’ll continue to see you right now.